school is right around the corner just a
few days away it's approaching fast it
can be hard though to keep your child
motivated engaged in learning with so
many things competing for their
attention mary jane belliesa is live now
at sunset montessori community on sunset
and pecos with how experts say you can
help your child prepare for the school
year there's so much that can take their
attention right mary jane
oh sherry absolutely and like you said
i'm here at sunset montessori a local
school in the southeast valley i'm
joined brian early with gail swift she
is a colby youth advocate and gail thank
you so much for waking up with us now
tell us what is a colby youth advocate
and how do you help parents and children
a colby youth advocate gives children
students the opportunity to know how
they solve problems their way
and when they know how they solve
problems their way through a tool that i
use they have motivation
to learn and to keep learning throughout
the year and as we know that's really
important as kids go back to school they
had summer off they weren't thinking
about school maybe in the slightest
until you know right around next week
and how are you helping parents and kids
during that time
when students know and can identify
their way of solving problems it's not
the drudgery of having johnny or susie
be forced into homework or projects or
wanting to go to school because when we
know how they work the motivation is
there and they actually desire to learn
and keep that going and it's through a
test that takes about 30 minutes
that i do with the student and that's
really interesting to learn because i
think that's a big misconception right
that's something that you can't change
this is innate this is the student is
born with this way of taking action it
is not your personality you cannot
change it so i have a phrase that i use
going with the grain instead of against
the grain for your students best efforts
and that's also important to remember
that everyone has different learning
styles so it's really how you work with
your child to really help them get
motivated to get back into school and
keep them motivated all year long
absolutely yes this keeps them motivated
perfect well thank you so much gail you
know coming up in our next half hour
we'll meet with the owner of the school
victoria montessori as well as
her being a mom and what she's doing to
really help her students get engaged all
year long reporting live mary jane
bellassa live local now mary jean thank
you very much all right let's talk talk
more about back to school downtown
container park holding its annual back
to school event on sunday they're going
to have some live performances there
some local dance schools will be
performing there's free school supplies
available all sorts of interactive
activities starts at 10 30 in the
morning don't forget you can find out
more information on the container parks
website they've got that little stage
there a little grassland you can play
around with the kids have some good
times oh man there's going to be so much
going on this weekend as parents kind of
like scramble to get back ready
we'll get you ready though 12 minutes
past five next on good day las vegas
will remember
the greatest of the great one of the
best sports announcers ever probably the
best i would say so yeah i'm slightly
biased i'll look back at the late great
vin scully what's up next
also washington snaps the las vegas aces
winning streak we'll have the heartbreak
on the hardwood on good day las vegas
las vegas now
you're watching good day las vegas with
john langler
heather mills
sheri swensk and nate tannenbaum
good day las vegas live local now
let's go to the hardwood this morning
where the aces hit a bump in the road
last night against the washington
mystics it did snap their four-game
winning streak the aces scored their
second fewest points in the season they
lost
83-73 the road trip continues tomorrow
in big d texas all right 5 16 preseason
football starts tomorrow for the las
vegas
they're in canton ohio for the hall of
fame game las vegas takes on
jacksonville don't expect any big names
to suit up and play however kickoff is
tomorrow at five o'clock heather and
nate
to baseball
a man considered
by many to be the voice of their
childhood and the voice of baseball
really he's passed away right here on
your screen legendary dodgers announcer
vin scully passed away at the age of 94.
i've always felt
that you folks in the stands
have been far far important to me
you're the wings beneath the team's
wings you're the team
beneath my win
well scully's career spanned generations
that was his uh retirement back in 2016
but he started when the dodgers were in
brooklyn in 1950 and he did move with
the team to la 1957 calling literally
thousands of games he retired again in
2016 and
i think as much as the fans loved him
he loved the fans absolutely
the player everybody i mean he's
such a great guy he announced several
world series games did play-by-play in
fact for nfl games as well team's
president called him one of the greatest
voices in all of sports and it looks
like they're doing the candlelight
tributes there at dodger stadium as they
should and they uh i don't know when
they did it but it wasn't too long ago
they renamed the street leading into
dodger stadiums vince cauley drive oh
yeah and it's the vin scully broadcast
booth how great that you just got to see
that yeah we were just at dodger stadium
and uh i am wearing my uh
los angeles dodgers bow tie today in
honor of vin scully because um
it's a big deal yeah you'll missed we've
been playing clips of him all morning
long during the commercial breaks it's
been fun to reminisce i'm sure he was
happy about the move to california as
far as weather goes you think don't you
think
so
brooklyn to l.a oh yeah
or may he rest in peace yeah quite a
legend we've got beautiful skies this
morning everybody we've got a few high
clouds out there right now
it is so pretty those high clouds always
give color to the sky at sunrise and
sunset it is muggy out there though we
have
dew points in the low 60s and humidity
that's a little less than 50 percent
lots of 80s couple of spots still in the
90s green valley's right at 90 degrees
86 at nellis 89 downtown mid-80s at the
lakes and 77 right now at red rock
regionally looking outside the valley
only slightly cooler indian springs at
77. callahan is in the mid 60s ealy in
the mid 50s and we've got 60s tonepaw to
near 70 up there in reno death valley's
still in the very warm mid 90s with 80
in perump 80 in searchlight 91 in
laughlin at this hour our wednesday
looks like it'll be just as hot as our
tuesday afternoon at 102 that's where we
were yesterday just slightly below the
normal average high for early august 104
sunrise 5 49 in sunset at 7 44 p.m
there's still plenty of moisture down
here in the southwest what you see out
here offshore off the west coast this is
from tropical storm frank which
continues to be pulled up into the west
coast added to the moisture to fire off
a few thunderstorms up in north central
nevada yesterday things are kind of
quiet up in the northwest the heat is
waning a little bit now thank goodness
for the pacific northwest but we are
looking at a flareup of showers and
thunderstorms across the midwest today
the ohio valley and a lot of heat again
through the plains the mid-south even
into the ohio valley with heat warnings
and advisories posted for many states
again and you know they're still
searching for missing people and all
that kentucky flooding and they're cut
off with washed out roads and such so
the search continues and it's so hot and
humid there so many people still without
power all right so we'll watch for the
today will be really our easiest day for
the rest of the week and we're only
stating a little slight little chance of
some thunderstorms the focus will be
over the mountains we saw a few
flare-ups there yesterday one little
bitty cell that showed up right around
six o'clock dinner time last night today
we just have to watch the skies if
you're going to the mountains the higher
elevations that's where you should
really be aware of thunderstorms that
could pop up today then another surge
comes from the monsoon moisture tomorrow
i mean it comes up fast 30 to 50 percent
chance of storms thursday friday slight
chances left through the weekend and
will drop back to the 90s for highs all
right let's get to the roads take a look
at the drive at 5 20 nate all right
we've been following a lot going on on
the big squeeze this morning during the
4 a.m hour down to one lane super backed
up at the spaghetti bowl they had the
ramp to the south 15 shut down his back
opens let's head on down there looks
like they're even taking away all of the
cones so it's much looser here after
eastern into the spaghetti bowl but just
a couple of seconds ago there were some
uh road crews here taking away the cones
so it looks like just this one little
stretch here where it's backed up this
should loosen up for it looks like
they're going to be giving you all lanes
on the northbound side of the 95 515
heading into the downtown area now the
southbound side has been unaffected and
speaking of the freeway system it is all
looking pretty good right now no crashes
to report you have a couple of slowdowns
up in the centennial bowl we'll be
watching for crashes on the surface
streets and throughout the freeways as
well throughout good day las vegas hey
coming up you know those shore girl
statues on las vegas boulevard near the
strat they're missing and a viewer wants
to know what happened to him the answer
is next in what's driving you crazy on
good day lost
[ __ ] enough said call ed
5 25 on your wednesday morning viewer
john wants to know hey what happened to
the show girl statues there on las vegas
boulevard across from the strat
when the city of las vegas put that
fancy arch thingy next to the strat they
also built a photo op nearby with an
oversized roulette wheel giant dice and
gambling chips along with two showgirl
statues but a few weeks ago the
showgirls disappeared
so what happened
did someone complain were they kidnapped
well it turns out it's only las vegas
mayor carolyn goodman thinking big
about those 25 foot tall showgirls i
felt they were way too small so they are
being reborn as two new showgirls 50
feet tall oh
but don't worry about those original
statues they've already found a new home
where las vegas boulevard splits off at
4th street near the arts district
as for when those twice as big showgirls
are going to move in near the strap the
city's chase radke's got the perfect
showbiz answer he says
coming soon thanks for your question
john buckle up drive carefully please
put down that phone and you can join the
driving to crazy conversation at traffic
8 8newsnow.com
just ahead we'll tell you how metro
police are cracking down on illegal
street racing plus how hotels are facing
unique challenges all over the country
as we all live with the coronavirus
thank you for watching good day las
vegas live
local now
11 a.m and 7 p.m in summer
good morning now on good day an effort
to keep criminals off the las vegas
strip we'll talk about clark county's
new ordinance and how it would work plus
take a look at your screen do you
recognize this guy do you know him
police say he was posing as a health
inspector and got away with a lot of
money
also
how about after hours at cowabunga bay
we'll tell you about a one night adults
only event good day las vegas starts
right now
now
this is good day las vegas live local
now 5 30 good wednesday morning everyone
thanks for waking up with us today
what a beautiful beautiful sunrise huh
well it's on the way it's not behind us
i know i was looking over there
but it's coming it's nice we're teasing
them
muggy out there though still yeah yeah
it's all right though we can this is a
nice little change of pace because we're
not getting hammered with rain it's
august and this is the way august goes
everybody if you're new to las vegas and
you're like what is all this humidity
these clouds this rain thunderstorm
sherry keeps talking about well this is
monsoon season this is the way our our
summer goes it's been very active we've
been very lucky to get some nice
rainfall so far this summer today is
probably going to be our easiest day
though for the rest of the week do have
some clouds out there there's still
plenty of moisture around but there's
not much instability in the atmosphere
to trigger storms today so we're going
to relax a little bit you can all you
always have to just keep at least one
eye to the sky when we've got this much
moisture out there with dew points in
the 60s humidity near 50 percent and
look at all those 80s out there a slight
southwest breeze in a few neighborhoods
this morning we'll look for upper 80s
mostly sunny skies mid morning on our
way to some hot mid 90s by noontime
we'll look for clouds over the mountains
again building up because we do expect
to see the focus of thunderstorms in the
higher elevations today just a very
slight chance of thunderstorms for the
valley it's about 10 percent or less
today and hot at 102 that's where we
were yesterday we just had one little
cell that popped up around dinner time
and it didn't last very long so if you
are going to the mountains hiking or
whatnot just make sure you're watching
for that lightning and those heavy
downpours all right let's get to the
drive
those clouds are super impressive they
just don't usually do much down here not
here yes we'll be keeping an eye on that
also keep an eye on the freeways just
now getting report of a crash on sahara
where it goes uh underneath the 95 515
uh so we'll check that out around
sandhill in the meantime much better
news from the big squeeze now normally
we suggest that this is the best time to
get out there and it is right now but
man in the four o'clock hour and just
the first half of this hour
it was really tight down to one lane all
of the cones are gone and you have full
access here you can see some of the work
crews still off on the right shoulder
around eastern so this is the north 95
the taillights these are folks getting
off at eastern south boundaries heading
towards the charleston curve again the
freeway system and the surface streets
are looking pretty good we'll check out
the report of a crash at sahara and
sandhill and have an update for in our
next report heather nate thank you it is
5 32 this morning county leaders moving
forward with plans that they hope will
make the striff safer the new ordinance
would ban anyone convicted of a crime
within the resort corridor from
returning up to a year clark county
commissioner jim gibson says this new
ruling won't be enacted right away but
should be in the next couple months
it is not going to be enforceable until
a few other things have been done and
metro of course will have to be trained
in what all this means right so they'll
have to know the corridor and we're
hopeful and expecting that this will
give us results
now as of right now the new ordinance
does not apply to pedestrian bridges
which have notoriously been a problem
if you would like to look at the full
map the designated corridor we've posted
that at eight news now dot com and north
of this trip city leaders gathering to
discuss possible changes regarding who
can be on fremont street at night city
council will be revisiting a possible
curfew for that area during today's
meeting it would ban anyone under the
age of 21 from fremont street between 9
p.m and 5 a.m the proposal came after a
spike in violence there 5 33 on a
wednesday morning new this morning the
crackdown on illegal street racing metro
police say their new unit dedicated to
getting those bad drivers off the road
has made more than 100 arrests this year
officers have also issued more than 120
citations and impounded about 125 cars
police say most of these offenders are
locals heather
she says she tried to get her family
away from violence violence found them
anyway april vargas is the mother of 19
year old samir smith who was shot and
killed last week shooting happened
friday night on cindy sue street near
rancho and vegas drive metro police say
smith and his neighbor 24 year old
deanna maria diaz were inside of her
apartment two men knocked on the door
diaz answered but investigators say
smith and the two men started arguing
smith and diaz were shot and killed
i moved out here from chicago to get
kids away from shootings and
my son died out here from getting shot
and
now i don't even want to go back to that
place
metro police have not made any arrests
so if you have any information they're
asking that you call crime stoppers that
number is on your screen this morning
metro police are looking for this man if
you look at your screen you can see him
they say that he was posing as a health
inspector and stole from valley
businesses two fast food restaurants
robbed down in the southwest valley on
july third police say he was asking
employees to let him into their safes
while again posing as that health
inspector if you recognize this person
once again please call crime stoppers
5 35 let's switch gears now clark county
school district starts another school
year on monday and as students return
the district is still facing many
challenges one key issue is teacher
shortages yesterday we spoke with
superintendent dr jesus jarrah
i have to take care of the kids and
that's what my principles and that's
what my staff and and the entire 42 000
employees in this community are going to
do what we need to do for our staff so
we are deploying every educator in the
central office onto our schools we are
deploying administrators who have
licenses onto our schools we want a
certified educator
licensed in the classroom with kids that
is our priority
last week ccsd listed more than 2100
open positions the district is working
to lower that number but if you are
interested in helping too lower the
number well you can apply for a job with
ccsd we have links to apply at
eightnewsnow.com
metro and the lvmpd foundation helping
students get ready for the new school
year this week thursday through saturday
the department plans to give away
backpacks several different events now
kids do have to be present full details
at eightnewsnow.com
and before you get back into the school
grind you're invited to a free pool
party and backpack giveaway with north
las vegas
that is saturday
at the silver mesa rec center it's
happening from 4 p.m to 7 p.m they're
gonna have backpacks as well as some
food and snow cones given away
all while supplies last nate jerry so
much fun stuff i don't remember all that
when i was a kid snow cones let's go
let's do it
well it is the last week of summer break
before kids head back to school and
parents we know there are lots of other
things that probably have their
attention instead of focusing on
learning again next week so our mary
jane valdezza is live in the southeast
valley at a special place that
concentrates with experts on how you can
help your kid get ready for the school
year where are you and what's going on
out there mary jane
yeah good morning to you nate and sherry
i'm here at the sunset montessori
community it's a local school up here in
the southeast valley near pecos and we
are talking to the founder and teacher
we're inside the classroom now here this
is victoria montessori thank you so much
for joining us brian early now you're a
teacher so how do you help your students
you know get motivated for the first day
of school and continue to keep engaged
for the rest of the school year well
here at sunset what we have is we
provide an environment in which the kids
have the freedom to learn and because
they have the freedom to learn it
motivates them to want to learn even
more and it's very hands-on so they get
to choose they get to decide and i think
that that helps them get motivated and
also
keep wanting to learn and you know
motivated through the end of the school
year that's perfect and you're also a
mom you have a seven-year-old daughter
so how do you help her you know get back
to that first day of school that's
coming up next week well i do try to
you know make it exciting of like the
school supply shopping
getting the new backpack
also helping just maybe prepping for the
school lunches
we prepare them together
so she's very excited to go back to
school too oh yeah and that's helpful
you know like you said like you said
keeping your kids engaged really helps
them get into that mindset of getting
back to school and i think that's so
important for parents to learn
especially as a parent and a teacher too
yes correct that's perfect thank you so
much victoria appreciate it and of
course coming up in our next half hour
at 6 a.m we'll also talk to one youth
advocate who definitely works with
parents and kids on how they keep your
kids motivated for the back to school
year coming up reporting live mary jane
balliza live local now get those
learning engines going thank you mary
jane hey by the way we want to see your
back to school pictures as well
specifically for your kids but if you're
going back to school too that's cool
send them to the email address on your
screen pix pix 8newsnow.com we might
just show them right here on the air a
big day coming up but before that you
got to get all spruced up so if your
kiddo needs a haircut before school
pictures las vegas raiders would like to
help ccsd announced the team is
partnering with local businesses to
offer free haircuts and beautician
services the promotion kicks off today
and sunday for a complete list of
businesses taking part once again
8newsnow.com has all the answers still
to come on good day las vegas we're also
learning to live with the coronavirus
hotels across the country are still
being affected a week back we're going
to take a look at how staffing shortages
are impacting visitors stays and how the
hotel industry plans on bouncing back
and we remember one of the most popular
one of the best voices in sports
broadcasting the life the legacy the
career of vince scully on 8 news now
on cbs
[Music]
you're watching good day las vegas with
john langler
heather mills sheri swensk and nate
tannenbaum
good day las vegas live local now the
las vegas strip is always a top
destination for people traveling for a
vacation or business or both as hotel
bookings climb toward pre-pandemic
numbers worker shortages have made
maintaining their pre-pandemic standards
a little bit more difficult here's
skylar henry with more
as travelers continue to hit the road
for summer vacations those working in
hotels are adjusting to the rising
demand it's a little bit interesting in
that
there should have been a shift in the
type of business tashar agrawal runs the
jw marriott a few blocks from the white
house during the worst days of the
pandemic guests filled only five percent
of the rooms forcing him to furlough and
even lay off a chunk of his staff
now that guests are filling the rooms
again they have different priorities i
think what we're finding now is even
your business travelers are blending
their business travel with a little
leisure a bit of leisure travel and so
they're staying an extra night on either
end but not every hotel is adjusting to
the changing market the u.s travel
association says the broader leisure and
hospitality sector is still down 1.3
million jobs compared to before the
pandemic where is the biggest void it
was equal across the board between
housekeeping which continues to be a
challenge and always was but even front
desk in the summer and in the hot resort
locations
you know pool staffing and outdoor rolls
can be hard to fill experts fear the
lack of staff could impact the quality
of a guest's stay so many hotels are
boosting wages and benefits to attract
more workers you know the reality is if
we were back to three pandemic numbers
uh the experience tied to staying in
those hotels will not be the same as it
was for 2019 for anyone that was
traveling simply because hotels don't
have the the workers but agrawal says
he's building back his staff we probably
have over 20 jobs posted right now he's
optimistic the industry as a whole will
remain resilient and bounce back even
stronger skyler henry cbs news
washington
[Applause]
that is a voice that is the voice of
baseball the voice of the dodgers vin
scully passed away last night 94 years
old so the dodgers were in san francisco
last night taking on the giants but back
at dodger stadium fans gathered outside
leaving flowers candles and rightfully
so now the dodgers did go on to beat the
giants last night nine to five wow
that first uh clip by the way was what
88 right
oakland los angeles dodgers yes it was
serious
game one kurt gibson who wasn't even
supposed to play he could barely walk
and he hits it up and then they continue
with that in the year that has seen the
improbable
the impossible
and then he lets the he lets the game
speak for itself he was the best i i
love sports broadcasting and sort of the
main voices and watching them and
watching the clips over and over i've
seen that clip so many times it's just
perfect and john's digging up some
youtube clips that we haven't seen in a
long time he did football he did golf
i'm a nerd what can i say yeah that's
awesome man oh it's just such an icon
and a nice guy too you know they say
don't meet your heroes my dad met him
and just said he was just genuine and
kind and there you go yeah it was a win
547 let's switch gears uh let's talk
about late night swimming yes oh that
sounds refreshing 21 and over after
hours back this friday over at cowabunga
bay from 8 until midnight tickets are
32.99 a person and it's exclusively
available on the facebook page drinks
are available for purchase as well so
32.99 gets you in the door of the drinks
well you're on your own after that 21
and over yes right yes so not for the
kiddos that is correct
8pm to midnight
nothing beats the wave pool
in the dark i imagine it'd be a lot of
fun i think it would be fun yeah you
don't think they have lights out there
john well i mean
like neon and right i don't know it's
pitch black cowboy
we're gonna have to keep an eye on the
sky friday night friday night
possibly yeah in fact we may have some
overnight thunderstorms oh raining on
our parade
you know
stay tuned to the forecast because
things change every day but right now
we're looking at a pretty easy wednesday
so too bad it's not tonight of course
people are working i don't know that you
can do eight to midnight on a weeknight
but uh yeah so we'll
we don't wanna you know we don't wanna
spoil the party but we want you to be
prepared for sure for friday night uh we
do have clouds out there making for a
gorgeous sunrise this morning not much
wind i mean you can see the palm fronds
they are barely moving around on top of
the red rock casino resort camera out
there on the west side 84 on the strip
sunrise mountain summerlin 81 83 at
mountain's edge 85 at centennial hills
aliante about the same red rocket 77 mid
80s also for henderson right now
we've got some slightly cooler
temperatures once you get over into
kingman at 75 up to cedar city 59 this
jacket weather this morning mid 60s for
caliani closer to the valley 75 in
indian springs 80 in parump on the
backside of the spring mountains and
some mid 80s for boulder city and sandy
valley with those mid 90s still for
death valley mount charleston the
mountains will be the focus of
thunderstorms today
just a little lift daytime heating in
the higher elevations so we're looking
for mid 70s up there for highs and that
chance of thunderstorms definitely
greater up there we're only looking at a
very very slight chance this is just a
break there's just not much instability
in the air there's plenty of moisture
around but we get another surge of
monsoon moisture that will be coming up
from mexico later tomorrow
into friday yes and that's going to
bring back the chances for a widespread
thunderstorms to finish off the week so
we did have some thunderstorms in the
mountains and to the southeast of the
valley and then one little bitty cell
right there right around dinner time
dropped a little bit of rain not a whole
lot a little bit
as we widen the picture and look at the
the whole country showers and
thunderstorms across the great lakes
heading into the western ohio valley and
this is all that heat and humidity that
is still focusing over the central
plains the mid-south back over into
kentucky and that terrible devastating
flooding so many people are cut off by
all those washed out roads and the
flooding the high water still and
without power now they've got to deal
with temperatures in the upper 90s and
humidity so high heat indices well over
100 degrees 102 today for us that's
where we were yesterday and very very
slight chance of an isolated
thunderstorm but again better chances
for the mountains now that monsoon surge
brings back a 30 percent chance of
storms tomorrow
afternoon and evening and a 50 percent
chance of thunderstorms on friday and
those could last into the nighttime
hours slight chances left for the
weekend temperatures fall back into the
90s that's the trade-off you trade heat
for humidity and vice versa all right
looks like a bad accident out there nate
yeah this is mountain's head so anybody
mountain's edge heads up blue diamond
and rainbow they are right smack dab in
the intersection it looks like traffic
is working its way around here and it
doesn't appear to be a ton of traffic
but heads up anybody in the mountains
edge area blue diamond and rainbow put
it up here on the map for you i believe
it was eastbound on blue diamond at
rainbow the rest of blue diamond is
doing okay
westbound on blue diamond off the
freeway heading towards mountains edge
you're jammed up just a little bit there
around valley view that happens just
about every day again another look here
at this crash blue diamond and rainbow
looks like fire truck getting it out of
there this car appears to be on its side
so with the emergency equipment trying
to get anybody out of there uh we'll
keep you posted i want to rest the
freeway system you're jamming up a
little bit now south 15 lanes are open
just plan on tapping the brakes a little
bit john heather hey thank you coming up
here at six o'clock grab your swim
trunks or your bikini whatever we're
going swimming tubing in to be exact
we're gonna talk in the next hour about
how you and the whole family can get in
on some high speed tubing on the water
state news now
live
this is good day las vegas
now it is 5 55 here's a quick look at
today's top stories a new ordinance
would ban anyone convicted of a crime
within the resort corridor from
returning up to a year clark county
commissioner tim gibson says this new
ruling will not be enacted right away
but should be in the next couple of
months today the las vegas city council
is discussing a proposal a new one to
make cashman center a medical campus
that land is owned by the city for years
it's been home to of course the
convention center at cashman and cashman
field also for discussion during
tonight's city council meeting a
possible curfew for fremont street that
curfew would ban anyone under the age of
21 from fremont street between 9 p.m and
5 a.m the proposal came after a spike in
violence there
all right well you know they say a cat
has nine lives right well this little
kitten really already spent one of them
maybe a couple so check this out so
we're going to fort lauderdale florida a
kitten
was in an engine of a car
now they don't know how the kitten got
in there look i mean that this cat is in
the car engine
the driver was driving
how they knew the cat was in there
anyway they stopped they called fire
rescue they came they got the cat out
and they posted it on facebook the video
and within a day the cat was adopted
found their forever home so it has a
happy ending which is great news it was
really wedged in there huh
now you hear about animals crawling up
into warm car engines during the winter
months to stay warm raccoons cats
whatever but in the heat of summer in
florida right maybe it was trying to
avoid a giant bug bigger than it
alligators an alligator yeah that was
but it was in there right yes that's not
easy
trying to think about like doing work on
an engine let alone like crawling in
there and trying to whip you gotta you
got something stuck in your hands yeah
it's a cat
that engine's really purring
[Laughter]
oh boy that was funny because it's true
we're back after this
live local now
good morning now on good day safety
concerns before the first day of school
we'll talk about changes at clark county
school district to protect children and
staff on campus plus plans for the land
las vegas city council will discuss the
future of cashman center and the land
near the former heartland mansion and
back to school motivation the ways
parents can get their kids excited for a
new school year gotta get them off the
mat
gotta go back they gotta go back good
day las vegas starts right now
this is good day las vegas live local
now six o'clock it's wednesday morning
good morning to you at home and heather
mills good morning to you in particular
because you got not not only the back to
school stuff but an interview coming up
this hour yes i do we have firefighters
in the studio
and they're not here to find a cat maybe
find our cricket but
yeah they will be talking with them yeah
we'll talk about that uh
calendars and all sorts of whatnot
connections
yes let's talk weather as well sherry
swinson good uh yeah and you know what
easy day probably the easiest day of the
week so we don't worry about fighting
fires started by lightning today because
a very slim chance of thunderstorms with
lightning that could start fires thank
goodness but now the mountains still
have a chance of those thunderstorms in
the afternoon and evening that will be
the focus we look outside nice and clear
out there there are some clouds off to
the east kind of covering up the sunrise
a little bit this morning dew points are
high we're still very muggy with monsoon
moisture that has not gone away but
there's not going to be much of a
trigger in the atmosphere not a lot of
instability out there today so that's
the good news should be a pretty easy
wednesday for us 83 degrees right now
you can see we still have pretty high
humidity just a little under 50 percent
dew points are still in the low 60s
sunrise was 5 49 and 7 44 is the sunset
so we'll be pretty clear through the
morning hours temperatures are going to
heat up quick through the morning we'll
be in the upper 80s they will get into
the 90s even mid 90s by noontime you'll
see those big cumulus clouds building
over the mountains and that's where
we'll see the focus of some isolated
thunderstorms today in the higher
elevations if you want to go hiking or
get up in the mountains do it early get
out of there by the afternoon because
that's when those thunderstorm clouds
open up can drop some pretty heavy rain
102 today just like yesterday and again
a very very slight chance of isolated
thunderstorms for the valley today this
should be a pretty easy day then we go
back to watching for storms starting
tomorrow all right nate what are you
watching for on the road there's a crash
in the mountains edge neighborhood it
looks like kind of a bad one now the
freeways themselves not too bad south
15. you've got some company there
between flamingo and trop heading down
towards the 215. all lanes appear to be
open we'll for sure check on that but
let's head on down here to blue diamond
this is eastbound on blue diamond at
rainbow we have a car sideways and then
metro police are on scene now it looks
like traffic is working its way through
here but as we get here past 6 a.m this
is something to get busier looks like
it's smack dab in the intersection so
potentially affecting all four
directions uh wait till they get some
tow trucks and maybe uh medical
equipment in here that's gonna slow down
rest the freeway system not too bad
we're watching for crashes on the
surface streets and on the freeways for
you all morning long john heather all
right thank you 603 clark county is
moving forward with plans that it hopes
can make the las vegas strip a little
safer so there's a new ordinance that
aims to keep anyone convicted of a crime
within the resort corridor out
it unanimously passed yesterday so under
the ordinance if you're convicted of a
misdemeanor or a felony within the
corridor that's from sahara south to
russell road you could be banned up to a
year
if a person has been convicted of a
crime there and returns to the corridor
and happens to be
subject to
arrest again for something
or let's say the police officer who
arrested him recognizes that person
would subject that person to arrest for
violating
the order which has to be issued by a
judge
it is important however to note the new
ordinance will not be applying to the
pedestrian bridges at least for now and
we know those certainly have been a
problem in the past the new ruling will
be enacted within the next few months
today the las vegas city council
discusses a new vision for cashman
center this time its proposal to make it
a medical campus that land is owned by
the city it's not just cashman field
there's also a convention center there
as well there was an earlier proposal to
do something with that site it would
have turned it into homes retail and a
new soccer stadium but it never really
got off the ground also on the agenda
discussing the future of the land near
where the heartland mansion once stood
neighbors a little concerned about the
future development near charleston and
las vegas boulevard becoming a nuisance
so far there are no firm plans for that
plot of land
604 in spite of warnings from china
house speaker nancy pelosi visited
taiwan she says she's honoring its
democracy china does consider taiwan
part of its own one nation vision and in
response to her visit it's conducting
military exercises trinity chavez has
the latest
taiwan welcomed house speaker nancy
pelosi to the self-ruled island
democracy that china claims as its own
defying threats from china she is now
the highest-ranking american official to
visit taiwan in a quarter of a century
while receiving an honor from taiwan's
president pelosi highlighted the
decades-long u.s commitment to taiwan 43
years ago
with a taiwan relations act america made
a bedrock promise to always stand with
taiwan china considers visits by foreign
officials as a sign of recognition of
taiwan's sovereignty which china
challenges
across the narrow taiwan strait china
responded announcing new military drills
ringing taiwan and it warned that the
u.s would pay the price for undermining
china's interests we don't want to see
this
spiral into any kind of a crisis or
conflict
again we would say there's no reason to
for pelosi making waves with china is
nothing new in 1991 she unfurled a
pro-democracy banner in beijing's
tiananmen square today pelosi left
taiwan to continue her asia trip in
south korea and japan trinity chavez cbs
news new york
today the senate foreign relations
committee is expected to discuss new
legislation to strengthen taiwan's
defense the bill would designate taiwan
a major non-nato ally and provide more
than four billion dollars in assistance
in the next four years that does have
bipartisan support also in washington
after a delay the senate has passed a
bill to expand health care and
disability benefits to military veterans
exposed to toxic burn pits this comes
after republicans unexpectedly blocked
the burn pit bill last week sparking
protests the bill was already passed by
the house and now heads to president
biden's desk he says he will sign it
the bind administration is named an
official coordinator for the federal
response to the monkey pucks outbreak
robert fenton previously ran the coveted
vaccination effort for fema illinois
california and new york have each
declared a state of emergency over the
virus and the bite administration is
still considering whether to declare the
outbreak a national health emergency
here in clark county there are just
under two dozen cases seven minutes past
six hundreds of thousands of clark
county children go back to class on
monday the new school year brings many
of the same old questions though for
ccsd and at the top of the list is
safety there were several violent
incidents on campuses last school year
superintendent dr jesus jara says
changes are being made
we are
addressing you know the fencing that we
are seeing across
in our schools
were updating camera systems
recently trustees did approve plans to
improve security at a couple of the high
schools in town el dorado and clark and
add cameras on buses you can find more
of our interview with dr jara
eightnewsnow.com speaking of safety
metro police trying to help ccsd police
help in
school safety there and they're
encouraging parents to have
conversations right now about school
safety with their kids before the first
day of school
we strongly encourage parents to
continue to talk to their kids
and if their their students if their
children have any concerns regarding
anything within the schools to report it
both departments say students can report
concerns to them or they can use the
safe voice app and they can do so
anonymously sherry well school is less
than a week away but it can be hard to
keep your child motivated engaged in
learning with so many things competing
for their attention mary jane belliesa
is live now at sunset montessori
community on sunset and pecos with how
experts say you can help your child
prepare for the school year and get them
engaged and excited tell us more mary
jane
sherry good morning to you we're
actually inside the classroom now of
sunset montessori community and joining
me brian early this morning is gail
smith she is a colby youth educator
thank you so much for joining us can you
talk about what that is and what you do
to help parents and kids stay motivated
for school yes
the colby wisdom
measures
how people work when free to do things
their own way
how they naturally solve problems and
create solutions for themselves
when i work in a classroom with teachers
and they know how they work
and they know how the students work they
can allow the students to solve problems
their way and not
impose the teacher's way on the students
and i think that's great to mention
because like you said everyone has a
different learning style and that really
can't be changed which is a
misconception among parents sometimes
you're right this is innate
the student is born with this way of
solving problems and it does not change
over time it is not a personality and so
it's so much easier to go with their
natural grain
instead of against it wow that's perfect
thank you so much gail for that great
information reporting live mary jane
belliesa live local now
all right mary jane thank you very much
good to see what they're doing there in
schools next on good day las vegas
honoring the late legendary vince scully
plus the firefighters of southern nevada
burn foundation have released a new
calendar
for a great
cause
i'll tell you how you can get one
straight ahead after this break
finley volvo cars las vegas
you're watching good day las vegas with
john langler heather mills
sheri swensk and nate tannenbaum
good day las vegas live local now
welcome back it is 6 12 this morning it
has been more than a decade in the
making of firefighters of southern
nevada burn foundation releasing a brand
new calendar we've got it right here
all the proceeds
go to such a good cause they help the
victims
both in children their families burn
victims so guys i want to thank you so
much for being here nice and early we've
got alan and sawyer now you guys are
both with las vegas fire and rescue yes
so you're busy downtown uh tell us the
importance first of all before we get to
the fun part the importance of raising
money for the burnt foundation so we do
things year-round uh this there hasn't
been a calendar like you said in over 10
years i think it's 15 years okay and
there's nothing on the west coast for
sure so
a couple of our board members noticed
that there was something lacking and we
do fundraisers throughout the year and
this is just another one to bring more
funds like you said to help out people
throughout the whole year so there was a
need you guys are filling it um and i
don't think anyone is going to be
disappointed with this calendar i have
looked through it and um wowza
in fact we have mr april
right here oh thank you so how was this
experience i mean you got it you have a
full page i do and let me say i had to
dehydrate myself before that i had to do
get the pump and everything but no the
experience was really good the um the
volunteers with the burn foundation and
the photographers who participated all
had great energy about them during the
photo shoots and it was a cool pretty
unique opportunity for the firefighters
that volunteered because we all got to
got to meet each other there was
firefighters from six different
departments throughout the valley who
participated to make this calendar
possible and it was just cool to meet
everybody and yeah it was a positive
experience a little camaraderie and we
should mention there are ladies in the
calendar as well so so you have uh
gentlemen and ladies and uh i believe it
it's a fairly big calendar what
sixteenth month so yes so that is
excellent now again all the proceeds
here are going to benefit the burn
foundation you guys are having a launch
party tomorrow so folks can go and
actually meet you
shake hands maybe take some pictures
pick up a calendar tell me about the
event so it's at abel baker brewery on
main street tomorrow so uh august 4th
from 6 to 8 pm and anybody that shows up
uh i think the first 50 get a drink and
then anybody that shows proof that they
bought a calendar also get a drink
ticket
okay yeah and like you said you get to
hang out with
the people in the calendar you know kind
of mingle and uh say hi to everybody
it's a pretty good time i mean all fun
and games you guys look great obviously
but you're doing great work you're
heroes and you're giving back to the
community and so this is really a
win-win and it sounds like it got to be
a little fun too definitely it was it
was a great time hey so we'll do it
again maybe next year you think for sure
i'm pretty sure it was successful enough
that yeah we're gonna put it on again
next year and and sawyer already said
he'll do it again alan what about you
are we gonna get you in the calendar
next year yeah i gotta i gotta tighten
up a little bit but oh yeah i can get in
there i i i think they probably look
pretty darn good already but i okay so
you just you do some push-ups before the
photo shoot right
yeah that's what that's what the
bodybuilders do right sawyer can run
from summerlin to henderson and that's
how he stays so lean
you know what that's what we need in our
crews who are out there saving and
protecting guys thank you so much for
being on the show this morning uh sherry
i have a calendar it is set up at my
desk already
it's hot in here
i guess the weather is a little hot too
yes it is just a little bit you know
heather when i said earlier that i would
trade august if we were going to trade
months that we didn't need well let me
look at that calendar first before i
decide if i want to trade again i think
you're going to want to trade it i'm not
sure
i may just want to keep all 12 months
yeah yeah i think so 16 in this one
yeah maybe make a year and a half or two
year calendar at a time that would be
nice
all right guys we've got some high
clouds out there this morning a lot of
sunshine as well still have a lot of
that
monsoon moisture and mugginess out there
but i did want to alert you to a very
few nights how we had pretty clear skies
and we are in the season of the perseids
meteor shower which is one of the best
ones of the year august brings the
perseids december brings the geminids
those are the two best meteor shower
shows of the year it peaks this month on
august 13th but there will be a near
full moon by then so that full moon
light will wash out a lot of the good
viewing so
we're in it right now in the comet
debris for the perseids uh all the way
from like really mid july until
september 1st so you can watch many
nights before the peak and even nights
after for shooting stars and we'll have
maybe a pretty clear night tonight so if
you are out late
you might be able to get in on some and
if you start seeing some stray shooting
stars around even over the weekend if
you're out camping or out at the lake or
maybe up at mount charleston and you're
like oh wow i just saw a meteor it's
from the perseids this is the season of
the perseids meteor shower all right 86
in nellis we've got 81 in summerlin 83
at mountains edge and some upper 80s in
green valley still stuck near 90 degrees
this morning humidity is near 50 percent
dew points are in the low 60s i think we
can relax a little bit from thunderstorm
watch today but the mountains will take
the focus of storms today mid 70s indian
springs 80 in pramp right now low 80s
for mesquite low 90s in laughlin mount
charleston 76 today and that
that focus for the higher elevations
will come even by midday you'll start to
see all those big
cumulus clouds building up and we'll
look for lightning strong gusty winds
maybe some brief heavy downpours the
focus of the monsoon moisture this was
lifted all the way up even into northern
nevada also there's tropical moisture
coming from tropical storm frank off the
west coast and that's been aiding in
some of the moisture which has been
great for california they really do need
the rain showers that they've been
getting but not the lightning strikes
that could start more wildfires so as we
look yesterday
thunderstorms in the mountains and we
had a little cell right there on the
west northwest side around dinner time
didn't last too long we'll be hot again
at 102 that's where we were yesterday a
very slight chance of isolated
thunderstorms this afternoon and tonight
but then that monsoon surge comes back
tomorrow and friday especially we go
back to 30 to even 50 percent chance of
thunderstorms widespread including the
valley the lower elevations and slight
chances left for the weekend highs will
drop back to the 90s 6 20 let's hop on
the roads check the drive nate we got a
report of a crash at summerlin parkway
and the 215. now the 215 appears to be
clear here we're going to do some
searching but if you're in the vicinity
of summerlin parkway
near the 215 belt we want to watch out
for that one we'll certainly keep you
posted otherwise the freeway system
moving along in pretty good shape uh
still got this nasty crash in mountains
edge still got a car on its side
blocking the entire intersection
actually traffic is able to get through
here this is blue diamond and rainbow
it's metro police on the scene i believe
that the nevada state police highway
patrol also there here's a car on its
side you got the cones got some yellow
police tape here i did have the medical
crews on scene but it looks like traffic
is slowly working its way around here
but definitely something for you to
watch out for blue diamond and rainbow
john heather nate thank you a man
considered by many to be the voice of
their childhood the voice of baseball
has died legendary los angeles dodgers
announcer vin scully passed away last
night he was 94 years old
i have always felt
that you folks in the stands
have been far far important to me
you're the wings beneath the team's
wings you're the team
beneath my wind
his connection to the fans uh
unparalleled scully's career spanned
generations started with the dodgers
organization back in 1950 they were
still in brooklyn at ebbets field he
then moved with the team to los angeles
in 1957 he retired heather in 2016.
scully also announced several world
series games he did play-by-play for nfl
it's just that voice that iconic voice
the team's president called scully one
of the greatest voices in all of sports
and i think if not the greatest and also
he uh he did golf so the pga just
tweeted out this three-minute video of
him announcing professional golf back in
the 70s and 80s it's good stuff good to
listen to he'll be missed
up next the show girl statues on las
vegas boulevard near the strat they're
missing and a viewer wants to know what
the heck happened to them well nate has
the answer he has done some sleuthing
it's in what's driving you crazy you're
watching good day las vegas live local
and now it's wednesday morning
[Music]
sponsored by centennial hyundai
[Music]
now 6 26 on your wednesday morning
viewer john wanted to know hey what
happened to those show girls on las
vegas boulevard across from the strat
when the city of las vegas put that
fancy arch thingy next to the strat they
also built a photo op nearby with an
oversized roulette wheel giant dice and
gambling chips along with two showgirl
statues but a few weeks ago the
showgirls disappeared
so what happened
did someone complain were they kidnapped
well it turns out it's only las vegas
mayor carolyn goodman thinking big about
those 25 foot tall showgirls i felt they
were way too small so they are being
reborn as two new showgirls 50 feet tall
oh
but don't worry about those original
statues they've already found a new home
where las vegas boulevard splits off at
4th street near the arts district
okay so as for when those twice as big
show girls are going to move in near the
strat the city's jace ranch he's got the
perfect showbiz showbiz answer he says
coming soon thanks for the question john
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone you can join the driving
you crazy conversation at traffic eight
at eight news now dot com and good day
las vegas
between 11am and 7pm in summer
good morning now on good day the effort
to keep criminals off the las vegas
strip clark county's new ordinance and
how it would work plus
take a look at your screen do you
recognize do you know this man police
say he recently post as a health
inspector and then got away with money
and it's time to get totally tubular
dude yo bro it's jc man
join us for this week's edition of vegas
drives as we take on tubing look at
those guns all right jason you're stuck
on those firefighters so aren't you hey
las vegas starts right now
now
this is good day las vegas live local
now just been leafing through the
calendar haven't you the whole time i
was sharing the goodness with sherry she
sure was we needed a longer commercial
break can i just say that i didn't quite
make it through 16 months i know you
have to really you know you kind of have
to look carefully make sure you don't
miss anything right the ladies at home
know exactly what we're talking about
it's been a weird morning i just need to
make sure we're getting our date
straight everything put on the calendar
right heather exactly know your months
just check your dates
twice three times go back make sure you
didn't miss anything
i have almost nothing to add
one here
that's why don't add anything hey you
know there's some lady firefighters in
the calendar
these ladies have some guns i'm not
kidding they look good they're in great
shape it's 6 31. let's talk weather what
do you say sharon all right we're
shaping up let's shape it up to actually
be a pretty easy day for us weather-wise
now the focus of thunderstorms will
shift pretty much to the higher
elevations and that's with the daytime
heating not too much instability in the
air today have some high thin cirrus
clouds mainly off to the east kind of
covering up shrouding the sunrise this
morning off to the west we're pretty
clear over the mountains got a lot of
80s around this morning and it was a hot
day yesterday at 102 just actually a
little bit below normal for early august
87 mostly sunny through the morning
hours it's about mid morning around 9
a.m by noon time we'll be seeing those
cumulus clouds building over the
mountains though and that's where we'll
see those isolated thunderstorms best
chance will be in the mountains and for
areas north of las vegas today mid 90s
by noon all the way back up to 102 we're
going to keep in a very slight chance of
isolated thunderstorms we had a little
cell over the valley kind of the middle
of town last night around six o'clock
dinner time and that was it didn't last
too long today probably even fewer
chances than that 6 32 let's get on the
roads find out how the drive's going
nate uh freeways are in really good
shape that includes the big squeeze so
it's down to one lane during the 4am
hour all gone you're going doing great
there the 15 getting a little more
crowded we mentioned the potential for a
crash near the 215 western beltway and
summerlin parkway
summerlin parkway is where the crash is
over the beltway so the 215 is
unaffected here's a live picture not a
ton of traffic just a couple of flashing
lights there that is eastbound on the
summerlin parkway over the 215 a much
more serious crash still in the
mountains edge area going to watch out
it's right in the middle of the
intersection of blue diamond and rainbow
all four directions are affected still
got a vehicle on its side here metro
police on scene i believe that medical
personnel have come and gone now just
waiting on tow trucks again be super
careful looks like all four directions
are able to work their way through there
but that's a big slow down for you
heather it certainly is nate thank you 6
33 county leaders moving forward with
plans they hope will make the strip
safer the new ordinance would ban anyone
convicted of a crime within the resort
corridor for returning up to a year
clark county commissioner jim gibson
says this new ruling will not be enacted
right away but it should be in the next
couple of months
it is not going to be enforceable until
a few other things have been done and
metro of course will have to be trained
in what all this means right so they'll
have to know the corridor and we're
hopeful and expecting that this will
give us results well as of right now
this new ordinance it does not apply to
the pedestrian bridges which have been a
notoriously big issue
over the last couple of years for a full
look at the designated corridor map you
can head over to our website we've
posted it to 8newsnow.com
north of the strip city leaders will be
gathering tonight to discuss possible
changes regarding who can be on fremont
street at night
city council will revisit a possible
curfew for that area during tonight's
meeting it would ban anyone under the
age of 21 from fremont between nine and
nine p-m and five a-m the proposal came
after a spike in violence there new this
morning the crackdown on illegal street
racing metro police say their new unit
dedicated to the getting those bad
drivers off the road has made more than
100 arrests this year officers have also
issued more than 120 citations and
impounded about 125 cars police say most
of these offenders are locals
6 35 she says she tried to get her
family away from violence and violence
found them anyway april vargas is the
mother of 19 year old samir smith who
was shot and killed last week the
shooting happened friday night on cindy
sue street that's near rancho and vegas
drive metro police say smith and his
neighbor 24 year old deanna marie diaz
were inside her apartment two men
knocked on the door diaz answered but
investigators say smith and the two men
started arguing and smith and diaz were
shot and killed
i moved out here from chicago to get
kids away from shootings and
my son died out here from getting shot
and
now i don't even want to go back to that
place
so far metro police have not made any
arrests but if you have information
please call crime stoppers
right 702-385-5555 they say he was
posing as a health inspector to steal
from valley businesses two fast food
restaurants robbed in the southwest
valley back on july third police say
that man was asking employees to let him
into their safes while he posed as this
inspector well if you recognize him also
again please call police
sherry and nate
well you know there are lots of things
that can really take the attention of
the kids during the summertime
especially their minds not on school it
can be hard to focus
to get back in the classroom and
studying schools less than a week away
it starts monday and mary jane valjezza
is live in the southeast in a special
classroom got some experts who have some
tips on how you can help your kid get
ready for the school year hey mary jane
yeah nate and sherry good morning to you
we're here in the sunset montessori
community of course this is on the
valley on eastern and pecos and i do
have victoria montessori who is the
founder and a teacher here at the school
thank you so much for joining us brian
earley you know school's right around
the corner how do you help your students
stay motivated for the beginning of the
school year and through the end
well here in montessori it's very fun
and the kids have the freedom to learn
and that makes it very exciting and very
inviting and that's why they are
this is what motivates them to come
and to learn something different every
day
so this is the way that we try to
motivate them
all throughout the school year
and you're also a mom you have a
seven-year-old daughter and you know how
do you help her get ready for school get
excited and really help her stay
motivated
well i tried to include her and
everything that that has to do with
school so
together we shop for the
supply list
getting the new backpacks
um also
practicing for school lunches and you
know making me help
just make some eggs or whatever she
wants for lunch it's really the little
things to help you know get your kids
engaged and help them get into that
school routine very important especially
with school around the corner it's going
to be hard to turn on that light switch
right to get ready victoria thank you so
much for joining us reporting live mary
jane vallieza live local now
all right mary jean thank you very much
hey a reminder we want to see your back
to school pictures send them to the
email address on the screen right there
pix pix eight news now dot com will